Mi búsqueda es siempre por encontrar maneras de contar,
compartir y documentar historias sobre personas, simplemente personas cotidianas.
Historias que ofrecen transformación, que tienden hacia la trascendencia,
pero que nunca son sentimentales,
que nunca apartan la mirada de lo más oscuro en nosotros.
Porque de verdad creo que nunca somos más bellos
que cuando somos más feos.
Porque ese es verdaderamente el momento en el que sabemos realmente de qué estamos hechos.
Como dijo Chris, crecí en Nigeria
con toda una generación -- en los 80s --
de estudiantes que protestaban contra la dictadura militar que finalmente ha terminado.
Así que no era sólo yo, éramos toda una generación.
Pero lo que he llegado a aprender
es que el mundo nunca se salva por grandes gestos mesiánicos,
sino en la simple acumulación de suaves, tersos, casi invisibles actos de compasión,
actos de compasión cotidianos.
En Sudáfrica existe una frase llamada ubuntu.
Ubuntu viene de una filosofía que dice,
el único camino que tengo para ser humano es que tu reflejes
mi humanidad hacia mi.
Pero si eres como yo, mi humanidad es más como una ventana.
En realidad no la veo, no le presto atención
hasta que haya un, tu sabes, algo como un insecto muerto en la ventana.
Entonces de repente la veo, y usualmente, nunca es buena.
Usualmente es cuando estoy maldiciendo en el tráfico
a alguien que trata de manejar y tomar café
y enviar emails y tomar notas.
Así que lo que ubuntu realmente dice
es que no hay manera en que podamos ser humanos sin otras personas.
Es realmente muy simple, pero realmente muy complicado.
Así que pensé que debería comenzar con algunas historias.
Debería contarles algunas historias de personas excepcionales,
así que pensé que comenzaría con mi madre.
(Risas)
Y ella también era oscura.
Mi mamá era Inglesa.
Mis padres se conocieron en Oxford en los 50s,
y mi madre se mudó a Nigeria y vivió allá.
Medía metro y medio, muy determinada y muy Inglesa.
Así de inglesa es mi madre -- o lo era, ella acaba de morir.
Viajó hasta California, a Los Angeles, a visitarme,
y fuimos a Malibú, que le pareció muy decepcionante.
(Risas)
Y luego fuimos a un restaurante de pescado,
y tuvimos a Chad el tipo surfista sirviéndonos,
y vino y mi madre dijo,
"Tienen algún plato del día, joven?"
Y Chad dice, "Seguro, o sea, tenemos esto, tipo salmón,
que viene enrollado en esta, tipo costra de wasabi.
Es totalmente rad."
Y mi madre se dio vuelta y me dijo,
"¿Qué idioma está hablando?"
(Risas)
Y le dije, "Inglés, mamá."
Y sacudió la cabeza y dijo,
"Oh, estos Americanos, les dimos un idioma.
¿Por qué no lo usan?"
(Risas)
Así que esta mujer, que se convirtió de la Iglesia Anglicana
al Catolicismo cuando se casó con mi padre --
y no hay nadie más rabioso que un Católico converso --
decidió enseñar en las áreas rurales de Nigeria,
particularmente entre mujeres Igbo,
el método de ovulación de Billing,
que era el único control natal aprobado por la Iglesia Católica.
Pero su Igbo no era muy bueno.
Así que me llevó para que tradujera.
Yo tenía siete años.
(Risas)
Así que, acá están estas mujeres
que nunca discuten su período con sus maridos,
y acá estoy yo diciéndoles, "Bueno, ¿cada cuánto tiene su período?"
(Risas)
Y, ¿nota usted alguna descarga?
Y, ¿qué tan inflamada está su vulva?
(Risas)
Nunca se hubiera considerado a sí misma feminista,
mi madre, pero siempre solía decir,
"Cualquier cosa que un hombre pueda hacer, yo puedo arreglar."
(Aplausos)
Y cuando mi padre se quejó de esta situación,
en la que lleva a un niño de siete años
a enseñar este control natal, ustedes saben,
él solía decir, "Oh, lo estás conviertiendo en,
le estás enseñando a ser una mujer."
Mi madre decía, "Alguien tiene que hacerlo."
(Risas)
Esta mujer -- durante la guerra de Biafra,
fuimos atrapados en la guerra.
Era mi madre con cinco niños pequeños.
Le toma un año, campo de refugiados tras campo de refugiados,
llegar hasta una pista aerea desde donde podemos salir del país.
En cada campo de refugiados, tiene que encarar soldados
que quieren llevarse a mi hermano mayor Mark, de nueve años,
y convertirlo en un niño soldado.
Pueden imaginarse a esta mujer de metro y medio,
enfrentándose a hombres armados que quieren matarnos?
Durante el curso de ese año,
mi madre nunca lloró, ni una sóla vez.
Pero cuando estábamos en Lisboa, en el aeropuerto,
a punto de volar hacia Inglaterra
una mujer vio a mi madre usando un vestido,
que había sido lavado tantas veces que ya era básicamente transparente
con cinco niños que se veían realmente hambrientos,
se acercó y preguntó qué nos había sucedido.
Y le contó a esta mujer.
Y esta mujer vació su maleta
y le dio toda su ropa a mi madre, y a nosotros,
y los juguetes de sus hijos, a quienes eso no les gustó mucho, pero --
(Risas)
Esa fue la única vez que lloró.
Y recuerdo que años después, yo estaba escribiendo sobre mi madre,
y le pregunté, "¿Por qué lloraste entonces?"
Y me dijo, "Sabes, puedes endurecer tu corazón
contra cualquier problema, cualquier horror.
Pero el simple acto de amabilidad de un completo extraño
te descose."
Las mujeres viejas en la aldea de mi padre, después de esta guerra,
memorizaron los nombres de cada muerto,
y cantaban canciones hechas con estos nombres.
Canciones tan melancólicas que te quemaban.
Y las cantaban solo cuando plantaban el arroz,
como si estuvieran sembrando los corazones de los muertos
en el arroz.
Pero cuando el momento de la cosecha llegaba
cantaban canciones alegres,
hechas de los nombres de cada niño
que había nacido ese año.
Y luego en la siguiente estación de siembra, cuando cantaban sus lamentos
retiraban tantos nombres de los muertos,
como personas hubieran nacido.
Y así, estas mujeres producían una gran transformación,
una hermosa transformación.
¿Sabían ustedes que antes del genocidio en Ruanda
la palabra para violación y la palabra para matrimonio
eran la misma?
Pero hoy las mujeres están reconstruyendo Ruanda.
¿Sabían ustedes que tras el apartheid,
cuando el nuevo gobierno entró en las cámaras del parlamento,
no había baños para mujeres en el edificio?
Lo cual parecería sugerir que el apartheid
fue totalmente un negocio de hombres.
Todo esto para decir que a pesar del horror, y a pesar de la muerte,
nunca se cuenta realmente a las mujeres.
Su humanidad nunca parece importarnos mucho.
Cuando yo estaba creciendo en Nigeria --
y no debería decir Nigeria, porque eso es muy general,
sino en Urhobo, la parte Igbo del país de donde vengo,
siempre había ritos de paso para los hombres jóvenes.
Se nos enseñaba cómo ser hombres en la manera en que no somos mujeres
eso es ser hombre esencialmente.
Y muchos rituales involucraban matar, matar animales pequeños,
y se iba progresando, así que cuando cumplí 13 años --
y, quiero decir, tenía sentido, era una comunidad agraria,
alguien tenía que matar a los animales,
no había supermercados donde uno pudiera ir por un filete de canguro --
así que cuando cumplí 13 llegó mi turno de matar una cabra.
Y yo era este niño extraño, sensible, que realmente no podía hacerlo,
pero tuve que hacerlo.
Y se suponía que debía hacerlo solo.
Pero un amigo, llamado Emanuel,
que era bastante mayor que yo,
que había sido un niño soldado en la guerra de Biafra,
decidió venir conmigo.
Lo cual me hizo sentir bien,
porque él había visto muchas cosas.
Ahora, cuando yo estaba creciendo, él me contaba
historias sobre cómo solía clavarle la bayoneta a la gente,
y que sus intestinos se les salían, pero seguían corriendo.
Así que este tipo me acompaña,
y yo no se si ustedes alguna vez han oído a una cabra, o visto una --
suenan como seres humanos,
por eso decimos que las tragedias son "canción de una cabra"
Mi amigo Brad Kessler dice que no nos convertimos en humanos
sino hasta que comenzamos a criar cabras.
En todo caso, los ojos de una cabra son como los de un niño.
Así que cuando intenté matar a esta cabra no pude,
Emanuel se agachó, puso su mano en la boca de la cabra,
cubrió sus ojos, para que yo no tuviera que verlos,
mientras yo mataba la cabra.
No pareció ser gran cosa, para este tipo que había visto tanto,
y quien -- y para quien matar una cabra debía parecer
una experiencia tan cotidiana,
y aun así halló en sí mismo el impulso de tratar de protegerme.
Yo era debil.
Lloré por muy largo rato.
Y luego, él no dijo ni una palabra,
sólo se sentó ahí viéndome llorar durante una hora.
Y luego me dijo,
siempre va a ser difícil, pero si lloras así cada cada vez,
vas a morir de tristeza.
Sólo ten presente, que a veces basta
con saber que es difícil.
Claro que, hablar de cabras me hace pensar en ovejas,
y no de buenas maneras.
(Risas)
Así que, yo nací dos días después de la Navidad.
Al ir creciendo, ustedes saben, tenía pastel y todo,
pero nunca recibía regalos, porque -- naci dos días después de Navidad.
Así que, yo tenía como nueve años, y mi tio acababa de volver de Alemania,
y un cura Católico estaba de visita,
mi madre lo estaba entreteniendo con te,
y de repente mi tio dice, "¿Dónde están los regalos de Chris?"
Y mi madre dijo, "No hables de eso frente a extraños!"
Pero estaba desesperado por mostrar que acababa de volver,
así que me llamó arriba, y me dijo,
"Ve al cuarto, a mi cuarto.
Toma cualquier cosa que quieras de mi maleta.
Es tu regalo de cumpleaños."
Estoy seguro que pensó que yo tomaría un libro o una camisa,
pero yo encontré una oveja inflable.
(Risas)
Así que la inflé y corrí a la sala,
con mi dedo donde no debía,
agitando esta oveja de lado a lado,
y mi madre se veía como si se fuera a morir del shock.
(Risas)
Y el Padre McGetrick completamente tranquilo,
sólo revolvía su te y miraba a mi madre y dijo,
"Está bien Daphne, yo soy Escocés."
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Mis últimos días en prisión, los últimos 18 meses,
mi compañero de celda -- por el último año, el primer año de los últimos 18 meses --
Mi compañero de celda tenía 14 años de edad.
Su nombre era John James,
y en esos días, si un miembro de la familia cometía un crimen
los militares te detenían como rehén
hasta que tu familia se entregara.
Así que, aquí estaba este chico de 14 años esperando la pena de muerte.
Y no todos en el corredor de la muerte eran prisioneros políticos --
había alguna gente realmente mala.
Y él había contrabandeado dos comics, dos libros de historietas --
El Hombre Araña y los X-men.
Estaba obsesionado.
Y cuando se cansó de leerlos,
empezó a enseñarle a leer a los hombres del corredor de la muerte
con estas historietas.
Y así, recuerdo que noche tras noche,
podías oir a estos hombres, a estos criminales endurecidos,
apiñados en torno a John James, recitando, "Toma esto, Arañita!"
(Risas)
Es increíble.
Yo estaba relamente preocupado.
Él no sabía lo que significaba el corredor de la muerte.
Yo había estado ahí dos veces,
y estaba terriblemente asustado de morir.
Y el siempre se reía, y decía,
"Vamos hombre, lograremos salir."
Y yo decía, "¿Cómo lo sabes?"
Y él decía, "Oh, me lo dijo un pajarito."
Lo mataron.
Lo esposaron a una silla,
y clavaron su pene a una mesa con una puntilla de seis pulgadas.
Y ahí lo dejaron a que sangrara hasta morir.
Así terminé en solitario, porque dejé saber mis sentimientos.
Todo alrededor nuestro, en todas partes, hay gente así.
Los Igbo solían decir que habían creado a sus propios dioses.
Solían reunirse como comunidad,
y expresaban un deseo.
Y luego su deseo era llevado ante un sacerdote
que encontraba un objeto ritual,
y los sacrificios apropiados serían realizados,
y el santuario sería construído para el dios.
Pero si el dios se rebelaba y comenzaba a pedir un sacrificio humano,
los Igbos destruían al dios.
Tumbaban el santuario,
y dejaban de decir el nombre del dios.
Así fue como llegaron a reclamar su humanidad.
Cada día, todos los que estamos acá,
estamos creando dioses que se han vuelto desenfrenados,
y es tiempo de que comencemos a tumbarlos
y a olvidar sus nombres.
No requiere gran cosa.
Todo lo que requiere es que reconozcamos, cada día,
los pocos de nosotros que podemos ver, estamos rodeados de personas
como las que les he contado.
Hay algunos de ustedes en esta sala, gente increíble,
que nos ofrecen a todos el espejo a nuestra propia humanidad.
Quiero terminar con un poema de una poeta Americana llamada Lucille Clifton.
El poema se llama "Libación", y es para mi amigo Vusi
que debe estar en el público en algún lado.
"Libación,"
Carolina del Norte, 1999.
"Le ofrezco a esta tierra, esta ginebra.
Imagino a un viejo llorando aqui,
fuera de la vista del supervisor.
Empuja su lengua a través de hueco
donde estaría su diente, si él estuviera completo.
Duele en ese espacio donde estaría el diente,
donde estaría su tierra,
su casa, su esposa, su hijo, su hermosa hija.
Limpia la pena de su rostro,
y pone su dedo sediento en su sedienta lengua,
y prueba la sal.
Llamo un nombre que podría ser el suyo,
esto es para ti, viejo.
La ginebra, la tierra salada."
Gracias.
(Aplausos)